i think your book is is so timely and
you
obviously were working on it before
everything
uh that happened with george floyd and
uh nationwide it's called five days and
it's about
the five days at the center of the
freddie gray protests obviously you're
in baltimore right now you're from
baltimore
uh and so you the city's near and dear
to your heart
um how did you experience those protests
in real time
um and then how did this book come about
you know i remember it the whole thing
kind of begun
began when i was sitting in in freddie
gray's funeral and
and for those who who might not remember
you know freddie gray was a
a 25 year old young man uh in baltimore
who made eye contact with police and ran
the reason i say that is because that
was his crime
was if you are in a high crime
oftentimes high poverty area making eye
contact with police and running
is enough to trigger probable cause had
he done that in a wealthy neighborhood
he had been going for a jog but he makes
eye contact with police and runs
in harlem park sandtown winchester which
are two areas of baltimore west
baltimore deep poverty
and he's arrested an hour after he's
arrested
he's in a coma and when he when he's
finally taken to the university of
maryland medical center it is deemed
that he has three broken vertebrae and a
crushed voice box
and a crushed larynx and so there were
protests that took place in baltimore
for two weeks after demanding justice
and accountability saying you know how
is someone arrested
and an hour later they're in a coma and
no one has an answer
for what happened and uh and the morning
of his funeral i went to the funeral and
andrew was crazy because i remember
sitting in the back of the church
and i didn't feel like i had earned the
right to make that walk
up to go view the body so i just sat in
the back
and i left the funeral and i had to fly
to boston to give a talk on poverty
and the irony of that hit me really hard
that the night of his funeral was the
night that baltimore
started this process and that's when you
saw the unrest take place literally to
the point that by
six o'clock that night the governor had
called in the national guard
uh and would then put baltimore under a
state of emergency and a curfew
and um and i found myself in boston
talking about poverty both because the
work that i was doing because at that
point i was running an organization
um that i that i founded that focused on
helping students john first generally
first generation students
make it and stay in college but i also
knew they were there to kind of talk
about my past and my background
and put me up as an example
[Music]
and it was in that moment
that i started realizing how dangerous
that was
how it made me complicit as well wow
that that we can sit there and say and
look at the people who make it
and say it's because of them and that's
such a great story
and then look at ones who don't and say
it's because of them and it's because
they didn't work hard without
understanding the systems that we still
have in place
well that that's what your book the
other westmore is all about is that
that's exactly
right right it's about the same
neighborhood and what one winds up here
and then the other ones up uh
you know in jail that's right and how
and how we are so quick as a society
to either congratulate or to castigate
without being
willing to understand or indict systems
that we have in all of this and i think
about this in context and
you know earlier on this week uh you
know we had uh
the the the current governor of maryland
you know
he announced that he's that he's putting
he's putting out a book
right and in the book he starts talking
a lot about
uh this moment and he was the brand new
governor i think he was governor for
for uh for for three months at the time
when everything jumped off
with freddie gray but during this book
he spends time and
and the exact quote that he used when he
was describing
the when describing freddie gray was he
called him
a crips gang connected street level drug
dealer
with a long criminal rap sheet
i spent four years focusing on and
understanding what happened around
freddie gray and what happened in
baltimore around those times
and and here's what i do know and i can
say this definitively that the story of
freddie gray's life
is a story of societal failure because
this was a young man who was born
underweight and premature he was also
born addicted to heroin because his
mother battled
heroin addiction for much of her life
she grew up in deep poverty her entire
life
she gives birth to twins once the twins
are old enough that they actually gain
enough weight that they're able to leave
the hospital
they move into a housing project on
north cary street over in over in west
baltimore
and that housing project in 2009 along
with 480 other homes
were actually cited in a civil lawsuit
because of the endemic levels of lead
inside of that house so
you know and you know andrew it's like
you know the cdc right
the center for disease control indicates
that if a person has six milliliters
of lead in every deciliter of blood and
every deciliter of blood
that person will have cognitive damages
for the remainder of their life
right we've known this is a neurotoxin
for a century
if a person have six freddie gray
had 36. so this was a young man who was
born premature
underweight addicted to heroin
and lead poisoned and by that time in
his life
he's two and so when we're making these
judgments
about people by the time he was in fifth
grade he was four grade levels behind in
reading because of the cognitive damage
of the lead poisoning
you know he finished his last recorded
day of school in
the baltimore city school system was in
10th grade
and he was 19 years old he had been in
special education classes his entire
academic career because of the lead
poisoning and so when we're
i'm i'm hearing this uh where we're you
know
hearing the current governor making
points about how
well you know he was a he was no he was
no choir boy
he was no singer in the church choir i
know he wasn't
but i also know this is that freddie
gray never had a shot
freddie gray never had a chance and that
was the point
of all this is that we have to
understand all these moments and all
these periods
we have got to understand it with a
sense of context because the truth is
is that every system that touched
freddie's life whether it was the health
system
or the housing system or the george
education system
or our policing system that it not only
failed to help him
but it did severe and lasting damage
and now we see the product of that yeah
and he he dies in police
uh custody after an hour i mean uh like
that that's like the
brutal end you know to to a story of
institutional
uh failure and and
the tough part of it is that like if you
have
a set of systems or an economy that's
grinding people up
and then someone uh
dies as a result it's almost like a
reflex to say well what was wrong with
this person uh you know like
because that that's actually a more
comforting
stance and narrative than to say like
wait a minute like maybe we've had
uh problems up and down for years and
decades and generations
or even the fact that in his case i mean
you know he's born to a mother's
addicted to heroin i mean you could
probably trace some
some problems even before he's born
um to to various failures and this is
something so
the book one of the things in the book
that struck me was um there's a woman uh
i believe her name is tawanda jones yeah
and she's
she's protesting like uh i believe it
was her brother or
like someone else who uh
who was a victim of police violence and
uh so she's holding like weekly
protests before freddie
dies and and then the freddie gray
protests end up getting built into like
a pre-existing and this struck me
forcibly because you're like wow there's
like a constant sort of waterfall
of impacted families and protests
that pre-exist any one person where
everyone's looking around being like who
are you protesting because
because they had like like different
family members who'd been
uh victimized so that was one thing
where i was like wow like
if you're in that environment like that
that that is uh
mind-blowing for for most i'm telling
andrew
one of the most fascinating things for
me about the project of writing five
days
was first identifying who were the
people that i wanted to follow
over this five-day period that i wanted
to i wanted the reader
to be able to walk through this era
walk through this chaos through their
eyes through the eyes of these people
and
one of the first people i knew that i
was like i've got to make sure she's
profiled
is tawanda jones and because
it's important to remember that even in
the two years before freddie gray
right there was chris brown
there was anthony anderson and there was
her brother
tyrone west and every
wednesday still to this day in fact she
just had the 371st
straight west wednesday where every
wednesday she protests
sometimes it's just her and maybe one
other person and sometimes she's got
hundreds of people with her
but rain sleet snow doesn't matter she
protests and she protests the fact that
even prior to all this where she was in
and
she found ourselves and that's having
this amazing conversation with her where
she would say
you know i was so proud to march with
the grey family when they called me and
asked me
and i was so proud of the fact that the
city was standing up
and saying you know yes we want justice
and yes we have to address policing
but she said but i just also felt a
certain type of way where
i still thought to myself but where was
this when my brother was killed
right where was this when my brother's
body was literally left in the middle of
the street with mace all over him
and boot prints all over his body where
was this
and so she every wednesday she protests
demanding justice and accountability for
what happened to her brother
and and she was she was such a
fascinating
person to follow over that five day
period especially when you look at it in
context of who some of the other people
were right so
you had to wanda but then i also you
know you know spend time following
uh major mark partee who was a baltimore
city police major
who grew up in west baltimore and i
remember him specifically telling me
before where he said listen
you know i know that none of my
colleagues woke up that morning with
homicide in their mind
but i also know that for kids in west
baltimore where i grew up
i know why they don't believe me right
or or following someone like greg butler
who's a basketball star turned protester
or following someone like john angelos
who's the son of the owner of the
baltimore orioles
literally you know a billionaire who was
also the head of baseball operations for
the orioles
and base and and on the wednesday after
baseball played its first ever game with
no fans now we're doing all the time
but their first ever game with no fans
when the orioles played the chicago
white sox
and it was because john angelos was one
of the people in the room making the
final decision
of basically saying no we should play
the game even though the city is in the
state of emergency
because the world needs to see this and
so watching the various
and different perspectives of people
like that people liking nick mosby
who's a city councilman at the time
whose wife was the state's attorney
in baltimore but watching it through
their eyes
i think uh you know hopefully provided a
real kaleidoscope understanding
of the complexity of the moment but also
that
if we thought that this was just about
policing
or just about freddie that we were
missing a bigger point
that society was trying to tell us
something else that they were hoping
that we would actually pay attention to
well there was another fact in the
tawanda jones
narrative that also hit me uh really
hard which was that
um and i'm not sure if it was for her
brother or for another
uh victim but that they essentially
settled for a million dollars and gave
it to the three survivors
of the victim of police brutality um and
and that struck me because it was a
situation where it's like well
you clearly know that something went
terribly wrong if
you were settling with a family but but
there's no
um like no arrests made no
accountability it's just like there's a
death and then there's like some
uh some money and one of the things that
i found when i was researching the
extent of the problem
of police misconduct was that that
actually happens all over the country
where they're they're settling these
civil judgments to the tune of over a
billion dollars a year
in the aggregate um and so that's their
way of papering over this problem
um and so if you think about like the
the number of times it happens
and no one gets a dime or the number of
times it happens and someone sues and
it's completely unsuccessful because the
can you imagine trying to sue your local
police department i mean that sounds
uh like very very difficult to me you
know like like you you feel like
everything would be uphill
so the fact that you're still getting a
billion dollars under those conditions
struck me as a sign that the problem is
orders of magnitude bigger like if you
had to try and throw
a measurement on it you were like police
are causing billions of dollars
of bodily harm to americans
every single year and the fact that that
was happening in baltimore where there's
like no real responsibility but here's
some
like blood money essentially it's like
hey we killed your dad but you know
here's a little bit of money like maybe
that makes up for it like that also
hit me really hard it was and honestly
and i think tawanda's story is such a
powerful one around it because
she didn't take any money and it was for
that reason
because they also knew that with taking
the payment meant there was also uh you
know there was also a sense there's also
an and she's like i'm not going to stop
talking about it so she never took any
money
for right now but and i and and you
bring up an
incredibly important point because there
is this narrative
about baltimore when people say so what
what brought the temperature down what
calmed everything down in baltimore
and and oftentimes the narrative is well
it was when the national guard
were called in right that's not true
because you know first of all i can i
can tell you as a person who
you know very proudly wore the uniform
you know often times when
you introduce military personnel into
situations that doesn't calm situations
down
right but the second thing and the most
important thing to remember is
that some of the biggest protests that
were going to take place in baltimore
were actually set to take place the
saturday
after the unrest what happened why those
protests never happened wasn't because
the national guard was there the
national guard was already there when
they were being planned
what happened was was when the state's
attorney marilyn mosby
announced she was pressing charges
against the six officers
because up until that point you're
absolutely right andrew it's like the
the thread was common right something
happened
a payout ensued and it went away
that was a general trend right but
this was the first time in baltimore
history
where the state's attorney was actually
saying no
i'm actually pressing charges against
these officers for misconduct
i remember being there andrew where
there was almost this celebratory vibe
throughout the streets of baltimore
cause people were shocked people like
wait wait she announced what that
they're arresting the officers
for that because we hadn't we had never
seen that
before and now granted fast forward you
know we had two of the officers were
found not guilty for the officers were
their cases their charges were
were dismissed um but that moment
that was what actually brought the
temperature down because people thought
for the first time
we actually might see justice and what's
interesting now i think even when you
look at what happened with what's
happened with george floyd
one of the big differences i think
between then and now is the bar has been
risen
where at that point the charges
were like whoa that's a big deal calmed
everything down now
charges have been filed the bar isn't
about charges anymore
the bar is convictions and that's going
to be the real test to see
can you actually get convictions for you
know for
for these for these instances in the
case of george floyd when you are
literally watching
a grown man in handcuffs on the ground
with another man nonchalantly leaning
his knee into his neck until he can no
longer breathe
i mean the bar is not can we get an
arrest the bar is
conviction for that thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you